[Music]
hey
um uh nikki and and geo you guys are
like on tick tock a lot right do you
still consume tick tock i deleted it
we deleted it on the opposite every day
long too many times
yeah it was just it was um i read an
article about how they get your info and
all this stuff and i was like cool and i
deleted it you're like
chinese [ __ ] get out of my
phone and she read it on google chrome
oh so you know her date is safe
so you're still on no yeah it was just
addicting i love it i love it
so yeah do you like love it or for
reasons
of like like content just the content
creation it just feels like a very free
creative space
and then i get to because like on the
for you page depending on obviously what
you're clicking around and like the
seconds you spend on whatever you're
watching
it starts really recommending their
algorithms really good
i love it like everything they
recommended was something i liked i
loved it that's why it became really
addicting because it was like
oh [ __ ] i was on it for like hours at a
time i learned about animals i learned
about writing a children's book i
learned about economy i learned about oh
my god it's [ __ ] cool dude
google gets that google's like youtube
youtube is like
gordon ramsay yells at a refugee and i'm
like all right yeah i want to watch this
video
i would like to watch this so how about
like true crime stuff have you come
across that yeah
i don't uh i think because i don't like
consuming it because when i'm on it um
it's night time so i like happy [ __ ] so
i don't it does on youtube
because i watched a lot of true crime on
youtube well have you
heard of alyssa tourney
oh yes uh her dad right yes yes
yes i followed that girl they tried the
dad killed the sister yes
yes tell me the detail please i don't
know here is the story it was on a
mission
i was with her so this whole story is
pretty amazing so sarah turney
is alyssa turney's sister got it
younger sister oh really yes okay
[ __ ] forget it so alyssa turney
was 17 years old when she went missing
back in 2001.
she was last seen being picked up early
from school
from her or her stepdad or technically
her
legal dad because he adopted her uh
picked her up from school
now the whole that's not his calm though
hold on the family background here
is when alyssa was three years old her
mother
married this father that we're talking
about and so together they had
sarah and so sarah
is the younger sister of alyssa so sarah
was 12 years old
when alyssa at 17 at the time
disappeared
that's from his [ __ ] right yes yep okay
sarah is his biological daughter
uh but elizabeth they had the same dad
um
legally legally yeah so they were in the
same family yeah yes
okay and they both came from the same
period right yes
yeah the vagina was this where they were
shared
yes i see there's so much info to them
here's some more photos of alyssa and
sarah together so
sarah the younger sister considered
alyssa
her mother pretty much because when they
were really young their mother
passed from cancer and so that is why
the father adopted alyssa
and raised them together and also he had
other kids and so does the mom
but here we're focusing on these two
sisters so
when the day that alyssa disappeared
uh sarah got home and she noticed that
alyssa's room was like a complete mess
which is
out of character for alyssa she's ocd
she was
like she kept her room clean things to
mention
is that alyssa was working at the time
she had saved up about eighteen hundred
dollars in her own personal bank account
and the day that she disappeared there
was a note left behind
apparently in her handwriting that said
that she was running away to california
to go live with an aunt in california
and but the weird thing is that she had
already made plans later on that day
so why would she run away all of a
sudden when she had plans um
she also never touched that eighteen
hundred dollars that she saved
she left her cell phone behind oh and
her belongings
so it's like what the [ __ ] happened she
really double booked yeah oh a double
book
no so then uh i'm not good at that you
have cell phones like in the 90s
yeah i had my first cell phone oh like
the nokia or motorola
yeah exactly yeah so then um it was just
really strange
and so after that so the step dad was
the main person of interest here
in alyssa's disappearance but for some
reason or another the police
uh never really interviewed him or
interviewed any other witnesses they
just kind of
took it as a runaway case and left it
alone that's crazy
was the step that a [ __ ] cop oh
he does have that background oh
that was good that was good that's good
because usually
that should happen sort of like in that
realm yeah i don't know exactly
other than that that's where they look
the first is like you familial ties and
step
yeah yeah she was also somehow tied to
the military yeah i don't know exactly
how
but yes so then after years um
like years later that's when
her dad actually got arrested
because the police found a [ __ ] ton of
pipe bombs the largest
pipe bomb bust in phoenix history
pipe bombs pipe bombs he's about to
[ __ ] tank man this [ __ ]
and also he had a manifesto
he's about to tank man this [ __ ] he
actually got sentenced to 10 years in
prison but he served seven and so after
he got out
that's when uh sarah like so
sarah and she like i said he has other
kids so the other kids already were like
dad did it dad killed alyssa like
[ __ ] he's
killed her right but for many many many
years sarah was like no like i can't
believe it dad would never do that
i just i can't wrap my head around that
but then eventually around the whole
pipe bomb
time was when the cops told sarah
hey don't worry your dad's actually like
we're gonna get your dad on your
sister's
disappearance too there's evidence that
alyssa was being
physically like sexually abused by the
father
and and so once like all this stuff
settles don't trip
we're gonna get him for your sister's
disappearance but then after he gets out
of jail like
nothing is happening for alyssa's case
and so sarah
eventually she came around and got
convinced that her dad was involved and
she's like fully convinced that her dad
is responsible for her sister's
murder and because there was also like
receipts that he bought like lime and
cement like
a like a whole bunch of pounds of lime
and cement so
that's to dispose of a body and so um
there's lime so she's constructed
something the smell or
i don't know so she's constructed
somewhere like in a house
maybe like i don't know lions is cement
like they he probably [ __ ] cemented
her body somewhere
yeah i don't who knows so if you guys
are curious on this kid and even you
guys
she has a whole podcast called voices
for justice where she really like
dives deep into her sister's
disappearance
and she also has a blog called justice
for alyssa
and so there's a there's a ton of more
information more details that really
like it it concludes that in my opinion
my personal opinion as well
that her dad really did it and so not
until
like i'm telling you years and years and
years of her trying to get attention the
police said
you're never going to get anywhere in
your sister's case unless you get media
attention
so for all these years she's been on
social media she's been on instagram
facebook youtube
all that making her blogs never got any
traction
until tick tock it was good i it popped
up for me
and it was so cute
it was really good
where's my sister dance can you do it i
don't know i think it was a video it was
like a vhs
video yeah she has multiple ones where
she actually has vhs videos i think i
saw that one too of her dad
and her sister and at one point her
sister yells to sarah
dad sarah's i mean wait what sarah dad's
a pervert yeah yeah so he's like
alyssa actually told sarah that dad's a
pervert and then the dad was like
are you filming this or something yeah
it's his blood he does it right yeah he
never molested her because that's his
own daughter
right yeah so let me show you one of her
tick tocks and
this is not the one with the vhs tape
but uh this is one of the ones that went
really viral and thanks to tick-tock
we'll get to the happy
ending in a second i will well it's not
even the ending but
i did not expect to blow up on tick tock
overnight so thank you and you've been
asking for a story time so let me tell
you why i'm even here
in 2001 my sister-in-law's attorney went
missing she was 17
and i was 12. she was basically the only
mom i ever had but
everyone thought that she just ran away
and the police didn't even look into it
until 2008
seven years later that's when they sat
me down told me that my father had been
molesting alyssa for our entire lives
they told me i had a sister i didn't
know about and that they were raiding
her home
right that minute looking for evidence
that he killed my sister
but they actually found 26 pipe bombs
the largest python bust in phoenix
history
and i still didn't believe it but
eventually i came around and i said
how can i help you guys and they said
you know what don't worry about a kid
when your dad gets out of prison for his
bomb charges we're gonna go ahead and
arrest him for the murder of your sister
and i said great but that didn't happen
and then they sat me down and said
sorry your best chance is getting media
exposure so that's what i'm trying to do
please share this and listen to voices
for justice about alyssa
i love you thank you so her dad is out
and he's just chilling
here's the vehicle i don't know what's
in here
hit the red button yeah
dad's a pervert
[Music]
i also forgot to mention a lot of other
important things which was the fact that
this dad was
obsessed with alyssa and he was
recording her at her
job at like jack in the box it
apparently was her first job
and he would record her film he also had
hidden cameras in the house
and the cops found like the footage of
it and also
he was recording the house phone
conversations
and so she like sarah somehow obtained
all of this or at least some of it
because she posts on her tech talks like
voice
messages from that tapped phone of like
the dad telling
alyssa's school that she had a learning
disability which alyssa was never
formally diagnosed with and a whole
bunch of shady [ __ ] okay
a lot of shady [ __ ] but the happy ending
part the happy ending part
and the reason why i'm doing this is
because it's not completely an ending is
the fact that thanks to the media
exposure
and with the immense pressure that sarah
has placed on
the law enforcement yeah go figure her
dad has been charged with one count of
second-degree murder
like with alyssa's like finally so he's
apprehended it's like tiger king there's
enough pressure where all of a sudden
carol baskins gets investigated at all
and frankly and then she gets on dancing
with the stars in 1999
there was a student in ucla i was very
close to this family
i was on the inside of the story i
remember the story that was yesterday
1999 michael negrete went missing in
ucla and my best pal at the time
he was his brother and he went missing
and the fbi came and investigated
they barely [ __ ] cared and they
basically told
the mom unless media is interested
like you know it's going away and it did
and it did and this story has only
stayed alive
in reddit communities and like small
like like places where people just like
share
their interest in the story because
michael negrete went missing in the ucla
campus
he was playing a game with a friend at
like three in the morning he all of a
sudden leaves his dormitory
he goes to a bus stop and that's where
the dogs
don't pick up his scent anymore and
that's the end of the [ __ ] story by
the way
there's no follow-up to the story so his
friend could have killed him because he
lost in dungeons and dragons
correct it could have been but but it's
probably some
who knows we don't know anything but but
he was a half mexican half white
guy who uh wasn't that sexy to media
right and so nobody knows that story
it's it's not something that like
natalie holloway was a hot
chick who went missing in aruba sexy
sexy sexy
and then everyone knows about her
forever and they don't stop talking
about her while michael mcgrady's story
gets buried
two years because two years before
there's thousands of missing people
children just all over and so
that's probably why first and foremost
law enforcement kind of treats it as
like well [ __ ] there's so many we don't
know
and then when you get media attention
it's like okay now we can put
resources toward this which is but
that's what sucks is that sick this is
normal
thousands and thousands of people go
missing all the time
but it's no different than when you you
got carjacked and they're like yeah it
happens
yeah i think i think one of the motives
for him killing her was the fact that
she was getting more and more brave
about telling people about what a
pervert he was
she was telling her friends exactly and
then also like her having her own job
and getting more independence and she
was 17
about to turn 18. her whole life being
molested
oh my god oh um dude like
sarah turney man you're amazing if
you're watching i hope you are because
i'm a fan this is so cool like that you
were able to be so relentless with your
sister
and bring some justice hopefully like
the case follows through
and like the entire trial and everything
and the dad can really
pay for his crimes if he really is
responsible for it and google the
michael negrete story man because
that should be kept alive as well nobody
talks about it for sure and actually
i've been
i was looking at sarah's entire like
tick tock like her whole page and in
more recent
time now since her dad has been arrested
it seems as though because it's an
ongoing investigative investigation
she can't really talk about it and also
the prosecutors when they were doing the
press conference about him getting
charged and
indicted um they couldn't even give
details as to what exactly is
pinpointing him to the
a murder because they're they're
charging him with the murder
because there is no body so people are
like how how can he
kill someone if you don't have the
evidence like the body and
um but because of that they can't give a
lot of details and so she has now
focused her content creation into
giving more voices of other people
disappearing it's awesome yeah well they
also don't want to give too many details
because that's how they identify
potential suspects and and informants
too
it's like yo i have particular
information about this because of this
yeah there's a lot of reasons for sure
but i'm just like really it's just
really awesome that sarah has now turned
her attention
to other people in need because there's
like she's been reposting a lot of
a lot of other like this other mom who
lost her daughter
and like another sister who lost her
sister so and it seems like tick-tock is
going to stay alive just because who
bought it oracle i think
yeah someone bought it how much like
billions
a lot microsoft tried to buy it but
they've got to reject it but oracle
devices
like uh microsoft and google or
something microsoft from walmart
walmart that's a weird combo yeah and
oracle one
well oracle because they're gonna let
tick tock basically still own it
uh they're just a partner so that's why
tic-tac wanted to sell the oracle
because you get to partner with the
american company
moral of the story if your kid goes
missing hope that they're sexy as [ __ ]
so that you know the media cares yeah
i think that's a really good one
[Music]
you